[Music]
taking a quote from Steven Strogatz
since Newton mankind has come to realize
that the laws of physics are always
expressed in the language of
differential equations of course this
language is spoken well beyond the
boundaries of physics as well and being
able to speak it and read it adds a new
color to how you view the world around
you in the next few videos I want to
give a sort of tour of this topic the
aim is to give a big-picture view of
what this piece of math is all about
while at the same time being happy to
dig into the details of specific
examples as they come along I'll be
assuming you know the basics of calculus
like what derivatives and integrals are
and in later videos we'll need some
basic linear algebra but not too much
beyond that differential equations arise
whenever it's easier to describe change
then absolute amounts it's easier to say
why population sizes for example row or
shrink than it is to describe why they
have the particular values they do at
some point in time it may be easier to
describe why your love for someone is
changing then why it happens to be where
it is now in physics more specifically
Newtonian mechanics motion is often
described in terms of force and force
determines acceleration which is a
statement about change these equations
come in two different flavors ordinary
differential equations or ODS involving
functions with a single input often
thought of as time and partial
differential equations or PDE s dealing
with functions that have multiple inputs
partial differential equations are
something we'll be looking at more
closely in the next video you often
think of them as involving a whole
continuum of values changing with time
like the temperature at every point of a
solid body or the velocity of a fluid at
every point in space ordinary
differential equations our focus for now
involve only a finite collection of
values changing with time and it doesn't
have to be time per se your one
independent variable could be something
else but things changing with time are
the prototypical and most common example
of differential equations physics offers
a nice playground for us here with
simple examples to start with and no
shortage of intricacy and nuance as we
delve deeper
as a nice warmup consider the trajectory
of something you throw in the air the
force of gravity near the surface of
Earth causes things to accelerate
downward at 9.8 meters per second per
second now unpack what that's really
saying it means if you look at that
object free from other forces and record
its velocity at every second these
velocity vectors will accrue an
additional downward component of 9.8
meters per second every second we call
this constant 9.8 G for gravity this is
enough to give us an example of a
differential equation
albe at a relatively simple one focus on
the y-coordinate as a function of time
its derivative gives the vertical
component of velocity whose derivative
in turn gives the vertical component of
acceleration for compactness let's write
that first derivative as y dot and that
second derivative as y double dot our
equation says that y double dot is equal
to negative g a simple constant this is
one where we can solve by integrating
which is essentially working the
question backwards first to find
velocity you ask what function has
negative G as a derivative well it's
negative G times T or more specifically
negative G T plus the initial velocity
notice there's many functions with this
particular derivative so you have an
extra degree of freedom which is
determined by an initial condition now
what function has this as a derivative
well it turns out to be negative
one-half G times T squared plus that
initial velocity times T and again we're
free to add an additional constant
without changing the derivative and that
constant is determined by whatever the
initial position is and there you go we
just solved a differential equation
figuring out what a function is based on
information about its rate of change
things get more interesting when the
forces acting on a body depend on where
that body is
for example studying the motion of
planets stars and moons gravity can no
longer be considered a constant given to
bodies the pole on one of them is in the
direction of the other with a strength
inversely proportional to the square of
the distance between them as always the
rate of change of position is velocity
but now the rate of change of velocity
acceleration is some function of
position so you have this dance between
two mutually interacting variables
reminiscent of the dance between the two
moving bodies which they describe this
is reflective of the fact that often in
differential equations the puzzles you
face involve finding a function whose
derivative and or higher-order
derivatives are defined in terms of the
function itself in physics it's most
common to work with second-order
differential equations which means the
highest derivative you find in this
expression is a second derivative higher
order differential equations would be
ones involving third derivatives fourth
derivatives and so on puzzles with more
intricate clues the sensation you get
when really meditating on one of these
equations is one of solving an infinite
continuous jigsaw puzzle in a sense you
have to find infinitely many numbers one
for each point in time T but they're
constrained by a very specific way that
these values intertwine with their own
rate of change and the rate of change of
that rate of change to get a feel for
what studying these can look like I want
you to take some time digging into a
deceptively simple example a pendulum
how does this angle theta that it makes
with the vertical change as a function
of time this is often given as an
example in introductory physics classes
of harmonic motion meaning it oscillates
like a sine wave more specifically one
with a period of two pi times the square
root of L over G where L is the length
of the pendulum and G is the strength of
gravity
however these formulas are actually lies
or rather approximations which only work
in the realm of small angles if you were
to go and measure an actual pendulum
what you'd find is that as you pull it
out farther the period is longer than
what the highschool physics formulas
would suggest and when you pull it out
really far this value of theta plotted
versus time doesn't even look like a
sine wave anymore to understand what's
really going on first things first let's
set up the differential equation we'll
measure the position of the pendulums
weight as a distance X along this arc
and if the angle theta that we care
about is measured in radians we can
write X as L times theta where L is the
length of the pendulum as usual gravity
pulls down with an acceleration of GE
but because the pendulum constrains the
motion of this mass we have to look at
the component of this acceleration in
the direction of motion a little
geometry exercise for you is to show
that this little angle here is the same
as theta so the component of gravity in
the direction of motion opposite this
angle will be negative G times sine of
theta here we're considering theta to be
positive when the pendulum is swung to
the right and negative when it swung to
the left and this minus sign and the
acceleration indicates that it's always
pointed in the opposite direction from
displacement so what we have is that the
second derivative of X the acceleration
is negative G times sine of theta as
always it's nice to do a quick gut check
that our formula makes physical sense
when theta is 0 sine of 0 is 0 so
there's no acceleration in the direction
of movement when theta is 90 degrees
sine of theta is 1 so the acceleration
is the same as it would be for freefall
all right that checks out and because X
is L times theta that means the second
of theta is negative G over L times sine
of theta to be a little more realistic
let's add in a term to account for the
air resistance which may be we model as
being proportional to the velocity will
write this as negative mu times theta
dot where mu is some constant that
encapsulates all of the air resistance
and friction and such that determines
how quickly the pendulum loses energy
now this my friends is a particularly
juicy differential equation it's not
easy to solve but it's not so hard that
we can't reasonably get some meaningful
understanding out of it at first glance
you might think that the sine function
you see here relates to the sine wave
pattern for the pendulum ironically
though what you will eventually find is
that the opposite is true the presence
of the sine in this equation is
precisely why real pendulums don't
oscillate with a sine wave pattern if
that sounds odd consider the fact that
here the sine function is taking theta
as an input but in the approximate
solution you might see in a physics
class theta itself is oscillating as the
output of a sine function clearly
something fishy is afoot one thing that
I like about this example is that even
though it's comparatively simple it
exposes an important truth about
differential equations that you need to
grapple with they're really freaking
hard to solve in this case if we remove
that dampening term we can just barely
write down an analytic solution but it's
hilariously complicated it involves all
these functions you've probably never
heard of written in terms of integrals
and weird inverse integral problems and
when you step back presumably the reason
for finding a solution is to then be
able to make computations and to build
an understanding for whatever dynamics
you're studying in this case those
questions have just been punted off to
figuring out how to compute and more
importantly understand these new
functions and more often like if we add
back in that dampening term there is not
a known way to write down an exact
analytic solution well I mean for any
hard problem you could just define a new
function to be the answer of that
problem heck even named it after
yourself if you want but again that's
pointless unless it leads you to being
able to make computations and to
understanding so instead in the study of
differential equations we often do a
sort of short circuit and skip the
actual solution part since it's
unattainable and go straight to building
understanding and making computations
from the equations alone let me walk
through what that might look like with
the pendulum what do you hold in your
head or what visualization can you get
some software to pull up for you to
understand the many possible ways that a
pendulum governed by these laws might
evolve depending on its starting
conditions you might be tempted to try
imagining the graph of theta versus T
and somehow interpreting how this slope
the position and the curvature all
interrelate with each other however what
will turn out to be both easier and more
general is to start by visualizing all
possible states in a two-dimensional
plane what I mean by the state of the
pendulum is that you can describe it
with two numbers the angle and the
angular velocity you can freely change
either one of those two values without
necessarily changing the other but the
acceleration is purely a function of
those two values so each point of this
two-dimensional plane fully describes
the pendulum at any given moment you
might think of these as all possible
initial conditions of that pendulum if
you know the initial angle and the
initial angular velocity that's enough
to predict how the system will evolve as
time moves forward
[Music]
if you haven't worked with them before
these sorts of diagrams can take a
little getting used to what you're
looking at now this inward spiral is a
fairly typical trajectory for our
pendulum so take a moment to think
carefully about what is being
represented notice how at the start as
theta decreases theta dot the
y-coordinate gets more negative which
makes sense because the pendulum moves
faster in the leftward direction as it
approaches at the bottom keep in mind
even though the velocity vector on this
pendulum is pointed to the left the
value of that velocity is always being
represented by the vertical component of
our space it's important to remind
yourself that this state space is an
abstract thing and is distinct from the
physical space where the pendulum itself
lives and moves since we're modeling
this as losing some of its energy to air
resistance this trajectory spirals
inward meaning the peak velocity and
peak displacement each go down a bit
with each swing our point is in a sense
attracted to the origin where theta and
theta dot both equals zero with a space
we can visualize a differential equation
as a vector field here let me show you
what I mean the pendulum state is a
vector theta theta dot maybe you think
of that as an arrow from the origin or
maybe you think of it as a point what
matters is that it has two coordinates
each a function of time taking the
derivative of that vector gives you its
rate of change the direction and speed
that it will tend to move in this
diagram that derivative is a new vector
theta dot theta double dot which we
visualize as being attached to the
relevant point in space
now take a moment to interpret what this
is saying
the first component for this rate of
change vector is theta dot which is also
a coordinate in our space so the higher
up we are in the diagram the more the
point tends to move to the right and the
lower we are the more it tends to move
to the left the vertical component is
Theta double dot which our differential
equation lets us rewrite entirely in
terms of theta and theta dot itself in
other words the first derivative of our
state vector is some function of that
vector itself with most of the intricacy
tied up in that second coordinate doing
the same at all points of this space
will show how that state tends to change
from any position as is typical with
vector fields we artificially scale down
the vectors when we draw them to prevent
clutter but use color to loosely
indicate magnitude notice we've
effectively broken up a single
second-order equation into a system of
two first order equations
you might even give theta dot a
different name to emphasize that we're
really thinking of two separate values
intertwined via this mutual effect they
have on one another's rate of change
this is a common trick in the study of
differential equations instead of
thinking about higher order changes of a
single value we often prefer to think of
the first derivative of vector values in
this form we have a wonderful visual way
to think about what solving the equation
means as our system evolves from some
initial state our point in the space
will move along some trajectory in such
a way that at every moment the velocity
of that point matches the vector from
this field and again keep in mind this
velocity is not the same thing as the
physical velocity of the pendulum it's a
more abstract rate of change encoding
the rates of change for both theta and
theta dot you might find it fun to pause
for a moment and think through what
exactly some of these trajectory lines
say about the possible ways that the
pendulum evolves from different starting
conditions
for example in regions where theta-dot
is quite high the vectors guide the
point to travel to the right quite a
ways before settling down into an inward
spiral this corresponds to a pendulum
with a high enough initial velocity that
it fully rotates around several times
before settling into a decaying back and
forth having a little more fun when I
tweak this air resistance term mu say
increasing it you can immediately see
how this will result in trajectories
that spiral inward faster which is to
say the pendulum slows down faster
that's obvious when I call it the air
resistance term but imagine that you saw
these equations out of context not
knowing that they described a pendulum
it's not obvious just looking at them
that increasing this value of MU means
that the system as a whole tends toward
some attracting state faster so getting
some software to draw these vector
fields for you can be a great way to
build an intuition for how they behave
what's wonderful is that any system of
ordinary differential equations can be
described by a vector field like this so
it's a very general way to get a feel
for them usually though they have many
more dimensions for example consider the
famous three body problem which is to
predict how three masses in
three-dimensional space evolve if they
act on each other with gravity and if
you know their initial positions and
velocities each mass has three
coordinates describing its position and
three more describing its momentum so
the system has 18 degrees of freedom in
total and hence an 18 dimensional space
of possible States it's a bizarre
thought isn't it a single point
meandering through an 18 dimensional
space that we cannot visualize
obediently taking steps to time based on
whatever vector it happens to be sitting
on from moment to moment completely
encoding the positions and the momentum
of the three masses we see in ordinary
physical 3d space in practice by the way
you can reduce the number of dimensions
here by taking advantage of the
symmetries of your set up but the point
that more degrees of freedom results in
higher dimensional state spaces remains
the same
in math we often call a space like this
a phase space you'll hear me use that
term broadly for spaces encoding all
kinds of states of changing systems but
you should know that in the context of
physics especially Hamiltonian mechanics
the term is often reserved for a more
special case namely a space whose axes
represent position and momentum so a
physicist would agree that the 18
dimensional space describing the three
body problem is a phase space but they
might ask that we make a couple of
modifications to our pendulum setup for
it to properly deserve the term for
those of you who just watched the block
collision video the planes we worked
with there would happily be called phase
spaces by math folk now a physicist
might prefer other terminology just know
that the specific meaning may depend on
your context it may seem like a simple
idea depending on how well indoctrinated
you are to modern ways of thinking about
math but it's worth keeping in mind that
it took humanity quite a while to really
embrace thinking of dynamics spatially
like this especially when the dimensions
get very large in his book chaos the
author James Glick describes phase space
as one of the most powerful inventions
of modern science one reason it's
powerful is that you can ask questions
not just about a single initial
condition but about a whole spectrum of
initial States the collection of all
possible trajectories is reminiscent of
a moving fluid so we call it phase flow
to take one example of why phase flow is
a fruitful idea considered the question
of stability the origin of our space
corresponds to the pendulum standing
still and so does this point over here
representing when the pendulum is
perfectly balanced upright these are the
so-called fixed points of our system and
one natural question to ask is whether
or not they're stable that is will tiny
nudges to the system result in a state
that tends back towards that fixed point
or away from it physical intuition for
the pendulum makes the answer here kind
of obvious but how would you think about
stability just looking at the equations
say if they arose in some completely
different less intuitive context
we'll go over how to compute the answers
to questions like this in following
videos and the intuition for the
relevant computations are guided heavily
by the thought of looking at small
regions in space around a fixed point
and asking whether the flow tends to
contract or expand and speaking of
attraction and stability let's take a
brief sidestep to talk about love the
Strogatz quote that I mentioned earlier
comes from a whimsical column in The New
York Times on the mathematics of
modeling affection an example well worth
pilfering to illustrate that we're not
just talking about physics here imagine
you've been flirting with someone but
there's been some frustrating
inconsistency to how mutual your
affection seems and perhaps during a
moment when you turn your attention
towards physics to keep your mind off
the romantic turmoil bowling over the
broken up pendulum equations you
suddenly understand the on-again
off-again dynamics of your flirtation
you've noticed that your own affection
tends to increase when your companion
seems interested in you but decrease
when they seem colder that is the rate
of change for your love is proportional
to their feelings for you but this
sweetheart of yours is precisely the
opposite strangely attracted to you when
you seem uninterested but turned off
once you seem too keen the phase space
for these equations looks very similar
to the center part of your pendulum
diagram the two of you will go back and
forth between affection and repulsion in
an endless cycle a metaphor of pendulum
swings and your feelings would not just
be apt but mathematically verified in
fact if your partner's feelings were
further slowed when they feel themselves
too in love let's say out of a fear of
being made vulnerable we'd have a term
matching the friction in the pendulum
and you too would be destined to an
inward spiral towards mutual ambivalence
I hear wedding bells already the point
is the two very different seeming laws
of dynamics one from physics involving a
single variable and another from
chemistry with two variables actually
have a very similar structure easier to
recognize when you're looking at the
phase diagram
most notably even though the equations
are different for example there's no
sine function in the romance equations
the phase space exposes an underlying
similarity nevertheless in other words
you're not just studying a pendulum
right now the tactics you develop to
study one case have a tendency to
transfer to many others okay so phase
diagrams are a nice way to build
understanding but what about actually
computing the answer to our equation
well one way to do this is to
essentially simulate what the universe
would do but using finite time steps
instead of the infant has moles and
limits defining calculus the basic idea
is that if you're at some point in this
phase diagram take a step based on the
vector that you're sitting on for a
small time step delta-t
specifically take a step equal to delta
T times that vector as a reminder in
drawing these vector fields the
magnitude for each vector has been
artificially scaled down to prevent
clutter when you do this repeatedly your
final location will be an approximation
of theta T where T is the sum of all of
those time steps if you think about
what's being shown right now though and
what that would imply for the pendulums
movement you'd probably agree that this
is grossly inaccurate but that's only
because the time step delta T of 0.5 is
way too big if we turned it down say to
0.01 you can get a much more accurate
approximation it just takes more
repeated steps as all in this case
computing theta of 10 requires 1,000
little steps luckily we live in a world
with computers so repeating a simple
task a thousand times is as simple as
articulating that task with the
programming language in fact let's
finish things off by writing a little
python program that computes theta of T
for us what it has to do is make use of
the differential equation which returns
the second derivative of theta as a
function of theta and theta dot you
start off by defining two variables
theta and theta dot each in terms of
some initial conditions in this case
I'll have theta start at PI thirds which
is 60 degrees and theta dot start at
zero
next write a loop that corresponds to
taking many little time steps between
zero and your time T each of size delta
T which I'm setting here to be 0.01 in
each step of this loop increase theta by
theta times delta T and increase theta
dot by theta double dot times delta T
where theta double dot can be computed
based on the differential equation after
all these little time steps simply
return the value of theta this is called
solving a differential equation
numerically numerical methods can get
way more sophisticated and intricate
than this to better balance the
trade-off between accuracy and
efficiency but this loop gives the basic
idea so even though it sucks that we
can't always find exact solutions there
are still meaningful ways to study
differential equations in the face of
this inability in the following videos
we will look at several methods for
finding exact solutions when it's
possible but one theme I'd like to focus
on is how these exact solutions can also
help us to study the more general
unsolvable cases but it gets worse just
as there's a limit to how far exact
analytic solutions can get us one of the
great fields to have emerged in the last
century chaos theory has exposed that
there are further limits on how well we
can use these systems for prediction
with or without solutions specifically
we know that for some systems small
variations to the initial conditions say
the kind due to necessarily imperfect
measurements results in wildly different
trajectories we've even built some good
understanding for why this happens the
three-body problem for example is known
to have seeds of chaos within it so
looking back at the quote from earlier
it seems almost cruel of the universe to
fill its language with riddles that we
either can't solve or where we know that
any solution would be useless for long
term prediction anyway it is cruel but
then again it should also be reassuring
it gives some hope that the complexity
we see in the world around us can be
studied somewhere in this math and that
it's not hidden away in the mismatch
between model and reality
[Music]